but I thought John McDonald's speech was
very mild-mannered very gentle
he said beforehand it was going to be
very boring it wasn't boring but it was
clearly intended to make people a little
bit more relaxed as having him as Shadow
chance in the comments he's often quite
passionate and he's famous for grabbing
the mace in the middle of the House of
Commons so I think he wanted to present
himself in maybe a slightly more and
more like a shadow Chancellor
the audience did seem to enjoy it there
were big chairs for certain bits of it
on austerity on disability benefits
things like that they really liked his
line about tax avoidance but I didn't
sense the same excitement as I'd seen
previously at labor conferences but Ed
Bulls have been speaking that's probably
as much as anything because people just
don't know John McDonnell and they're
very unsettled by the massive change
that the Labour Party has seen
now there also a lot of new committees
and reviews on Labour's economic policy
his biggest policies were the changes to
HMRC and also a review of the operations
of the Treasury which will be carried
out by Sir Bob kerslake who's the former
head of the Civil Service
a conference has been more upbeat than I
was expecting it's been there's a real
split in mood between those who are in
the korbinite camp and who are very
happy that he's leader and these are
really licking their wounds after a
leadership contest in which they were
really surprised their preferred
candidate list Kendall for instance they
come so far behind
I don't see a massive change in
membership at the conference that's
partly because people have had to apply
for conference long before Corbin mania
started up but I think the membership
are very upbeat one thing I have really
noticed is that those who are called in
supporters online don't seem to be out
in force at this conference most members
I've spoken to are incredibly charming